a 50-year marriage
um but is it realistic to expect you're
going to be happy all 50 years
no but
now it's not expected that you stay in
an unhappy relationship generations
before yes because there are many
reasons not just because well i think
generations before would laugh at us to
be honest i think the wives from the
1950s would laugh at us when we leave
because we're not happy because you know
she's like i had a whole side chick
across town he had a whole second family
and you guys are leaving because you're
not happy
do you all come from happy homes with
parents that stay together
i mean not um
yeah i mean i did like i have two
parents they have 10 kids
and um i mean they weren't always happy
though and so what i would see is like
growing up my friends parents would be
unhappy and they decided to get divorced
and it didn't it wasn't really great for
the kids where my parents there were
times when they were unhappy and they
just figured it out
and just you know because because to
them it was always about us it wasn't
about their happiness it was about us i
couldn't attest to that um
my uh my grandmother
um
her my grandfather had a family across
town she stayed with him i always asked
like why didn't you leave and she's like
i just stayed with him i had kids with
them that was my husband and he had the
other family and it wasn't like she
didn't know about them or anything she
just stayed and that's something that's
very taboo nowadays to stay with someone
that has a family across town i think
it's just
easier for us to be like i don't like it
i don't want it i'm going to choose
something else
i think we've become quite
individualistic as a culture so we don't
maybe think about the community or the
bigger picture or like like raising the
next generation so you you put yourself
first and your own like
happiness first yes so i think that they
were
more realistic
in terms of what they could achieve in
the sense of
in those times if you had three kids by
a man you know that the grass isn't
green on the other side
like you might have been a brand new
mercedes but having three kids is like
being a cat d written off vehicle like
only man
how many men are really going to take
you on in in in that case and that's
just being
the reality of it and that's me like i
hate to bring anecdotes in it that's me
growing up around
loads of dysfunctional relationships
like
dude he really wants to take you on like
that you just your caliber of man that's
going to date you is not what and it was
like
when you were 23
yeah and also they didn't
i don't know when child support started
or when all of the government handouts
started but
if like back in the day that wasn't
really a thing it's like you stay with
the man because he's a provider of the
family if i leave that means i have to
take care of the x amount of kids that i
have at home i have to get a job take
care of them have to find out who's
going to babysit them take them to
wherever it's like i'd rather stay with
the man that's providing for the family
and deal with whatever stuff that he has
going on because
it's going to be harder on me to leave
than to stay but nowadays it's easy for
women to be like okay peace out i signed
a prenup or i get half the stuff that he
has or i get money for him from child
support so i was like okay either way
is easy for me to leave than to stay
because there is consequences and when
you take away the consequences of
in society like people
people damn near do whatever they want
you know because before you you might be
homeless if you if you left your husband
i know but it just like everything
you're saying is like you have to put up
with what he's doing or else you're
gonna be worse off now it's like well if
he's being a [ __ ] you can still leave
well but that's that's through the
mindset maybe like men you've dealt with
in the past haven't like haven't been
great i don't because that's i i don't
know you personally but that's that's
what an example like your example my
personal like my family so um my mom and
dad met when they were 17
love at first sight
40 years together
happy families
he left
i was in my 20s all right so he decided
after a year a bad year of marriage he
met someone else and he decided to leave
he came from a family that
you said this was your dad yeah okay so
i was in my 20s so it's not like i had
this like childhood where i was
hating men like you know
um but he came from a family
his parents were together very religious
he had
four
brothers and a sister
um none of them none of their marriages
worked mm-hmm
either through one of them cheating one
of them leaving they were unhappy i just
i don't think it's enough to say that a
woman needs to be a certain way in order
for a marriage to work because it's not
true
did you ever ask your like dad for his
side of the story oh yeah no yeah like i
was the one that found out about the
affair okay i confronted him the night
before he left and oh my gosh yeah i
would be so sad it was awful yeah i
can't even imagine but at the same time
they had a bad year and it was
horrendous i was living with them at the
time it was horrendous to be around and
i wanted him to be happy so i was like
go be free
but
now i think that was a terrible way to
deal with a 40-year marriage or
relationship they were together 40 40
years and he ended it in an email
he went away to afghanistan and sent her
an email to me and my two brothers he
sent an email all he did was change the
name from like each of our names and
basically
what he is
and she said
this is a woman that moved from country
to country to country she was with him
through the war like
yeah multiple wars sacrificed her life
like everything she wanted to do for him
and he still left one bad year
like it was horrendous
is that what he said he said it was one
bad year it was 18 months that he so he
was in afghanistan work stopped funds
were withdrawn and he came back to
england he hated living in england he
was unhappy she was unhappy because he
was unhappy they didn't talk they were
at each other's throats they didn't
communicate
he then sought solace in another woman
that he knew in school they reconnected
on facebook
like social media is out here ruining
lives
so
it's
it's not enough to say that and and this
is just an example there are many
examples of women being good we're good
women
and it's still ending so so i don't
disagree with you that like like i think
that's horrible like yeah that
that i'm sorry that happened to you
actually that's that would be that would
traumatize me
but the majority of the time women are
the ones leaving
and the divorce rate increased after
hormonal
hormonal birth control was introduced
so and i the reason i think women leave
more is because we're incentivized to do
so to the point we're paid
so because we can we can leave and take
half have you ever heard the phrase it's
cheaper to keep her
yeah
so so we don't have a consequence for
leaving which we had before
because we can take half as money like
most of the richest women on earth
um got their money through divorce
because if a man leaves with the kids
the woman doesn't have to pay child
support the woman doesn't have to
contribute anyways she can go out and
live her life yeah and the man because
the man is a provider he still has to
work and do everything but do you all
come from places where the man is the
provider and the woman is just like this
freeloader
i think that's no
that's quite divisive to say freeload
though because she's got different roles
yeah but she's got a different role